ع المدرسه على المدرسه على
[موسيقى]
المدرسه يا الله حاليا القصف جوا المدرسه
يا
جماعه جوا المدرسه قاعدين بيصفوا سامع
الفراخ مش شفاك يلا اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله تعال عي تعال علي روح
اك
شيه اه ه نقر هان فرقه هي واحد فرقه
الثانيه الثالثه حرق
هطل عنكم
الشيا الشيا هذه كلها عباره عن
شضايا يعني الناس امنين في هذه المدارس
كونوا نايمين في هذه الاماكن يعني تن
القذفه ه شضايا في كل مكان بتس بعدد كبير
من الاصابات يعني نامل من الله ان سبحانه
وتعالى انه ما يكون في شهداء لكن في
اصابات وضع محرج جدا حاليا احنا صارلنا
فتره مع الشباب بنحاول انه نجلي الاصابات
من هذه المدارس الى مستشفى ناصر الطبي
ومجمع الناصر
الطبي ربنا يسلم الجميع يا
رب طيب يلا جاهز حالك روح حملوها حملوها
في
الاسعاف والله الحمد لله على سلامتك يا
حاج
الحمدله